sup bro not much but I want to get a
couple things out of the way it's no big
deal
a couple things myself it's Monday bro
you know I'm saying now do you have
yourself a good weekend uh I had a great
weekend and a great weekend I did
nothing
it's the first time in a probably I
can't remember I can't remember they
took the weekend off or did nothing I
didn't even try to read or think I just
went with the wind
now did you do you have tennis help
elbow from Jack and Luke Rockhold off a
Friday Saturday or that's where that was
where most of my energy went and and the
neighbor busy I knew what I didn't hear
from me found a new man well what I have
a new boyfriend and it was Tareq and
Luke and Luke is now staying at my house
know when he's gonna leave using my
shower the whole thing but um yeah yeah
of course
well took a picture of him I took a
picture of his naked body and sent it to
my wife sent it to dove you hack no yeah
I sent it day well I mean he was I go uh
Lucas using my shower dove he's six foot
three how tall are we again
that's what I sent him but more
importantly I'm I'm doing nothing I shot
my special I'm just going with the wind
and I put in my earphones and I'm
cleaning the dishes while Luke and Tareq
are [ __ ] playing grab-ass in the
water with my dogs and I'm just kind of
rubbing I'm cleaning my dishes and you
know el lucko
and Luco comes walking in buck naked
buck naked from the hot tub so
everything's hanging locked up digged up
dict up and walks way too close to me
with his with his with his dick and
grabs a banana grabs a Nana I'm like all
right whatever I don't give a [ __ ] right
over mate with you and I walk around
naked together who cares we're men
and now I hear he he threw my earphones
Tariq is doubled over Luke is doing the
splits outside like my windows are open
and he's I can just see his three-piece
set brushing my [ __ ] my deck my wood
the wood of my deck okay you're a
[ __ ] dick off my to get a splinter on
his No
dude then but was eating the banana but
I have to do he was stretching and
eating a banana all right
I don't do the splits in my house in my
home in within my earshot fair then he
decides to get in the water and and now
tarah clapping and I look over and Luke
is doing a handstand so I can just see
his lower body was like straight out and
everything yeah the balls everything's
hanging down not a good look eyes
horrifying horrifying so that's what I
was weakened well again my aren't
one-year-old gay men okay boy this
weekend I had a chorus weekend cuz I
know psoriasis has spruce back it's
better now it's better I just had a
little I got a little carried away he
already goes day-to-day no cuz I saw you
on Saturday it was so bad you know why
cuz I decided I was with Luke and Tariq
excited and I ate a bunch of pizza with
them I was like alley dairy and wheat
why would you have an [ __ ] and I mean
I got this thing licked and iced up my
skin goes really no you want to eat that
wheat stuff alright douche
well now I'm back I'm good blah blah
blah I
that's all good I had a great weekend
let me ask you how your weekend was cuz
they're not got couple questions
my shirt looks like yeah they go I like
it leaf blower I don't mind your shirt
really you pull it off thanks but that's
a 5-4 shirt it is I like I like that
shirt on you um but I was you got a car
oh yeah I got a new car
now may I ask you a question
yeah God please when I pull in from now
into the office yeah don't look at my
car
um but do it don't like rap on I want
you off [ __ ] and they're like look the
other way like it's when I say that me
I'm being I'm being very not for me mm
not your type of car well it might not
be no inside of a car guys like you know
I'd rather seen a pair of Yeezys than
look at my car it has an airplane wing
on it it has a jet fin on it it's it's
purple the kind of purple that's like a
joker purple it's the jawbreaker vert or
purple like that you put in your mouth
and suck yeah that you get their tongue
it's you know so you guys it's a risk I
got race car but I bought a race car
it's you buy that bottle race cam no
back seats know about true race it's a
Porsche
gt3rs correct hey well no I'm looking at
the oh no I didn't know yolivos
I don't any matter but but I I noticed
that the the car waste I held the door
the car looks like it weighs about 17
pounds it's a race bike it's a race car
it's all carbon fibers it's a race car
and I will say I have no business
driving my car no no no use I'm not I'm
not I'm not
we're not smart hard I portioning not on
a race track you're in traffic not
really seen traffic I took that thing
out Saturday night you have myself on
the road watch I went with John's
brother took me and went out late at
night no on the road yeah
opened up think got scary think scary
yeah ready for that thing pretty sure
that's what Ryan done died in can you
confirm that chin oh he died in a
Porsche to get the Jackass guy he died
in either gt2 or GT also noted that
awesome guy who bought Walker yeah Paul
his was a Paul Walker was in the GT okay
this is a similar 911 gt3 Oh that'd be
mine Wow mine's Laura so mine's even
faster than that faster and you don't
realize how fast it is oh my God look at
that poor car well it's made of
fiberglass right so you're well know
carved the Front's all carbon fiber than
the the top is aluminum you know what
yeah I'd be trouble yeah so yeah my
car's faster that one that's that's
that's like rope that's what Rogan is
well you have that rhodium is that in
that you know your your fin is bigger
than that and Santa seems to sit higher
than that let me pull up or you don't
show pull it up your car no you can
people know what gt3 RS look like
emailed myself I get it no you had to be
the extremest you you saw that it was
available and then you couldn't help
yourself cuz you could drive down and
get it your dream car dream car your
brother your brother couldn't believe it
no there it is
the thing's pretty [ __ ] filthy
McNasty yeah well there's that specter
[ __ ] fin it makes me furious now now
that no this can make you're gonna perch
on this a little bit but be you know
flinch on this yeah I had to over in
today because my car's in the shop
the cars in the shop I can't take us
could what happened euro car didn't what
no because by the way you bought it from
euro car oh you should see
that place because I'm sure God I'm sure
dude got and boy do they know how to
entice amazing thanks sure do because I
called the day before to see if they
actually had it yeah sure do I said
looking at that MacLaren's i'ma cool so
I got there what the showroom look like
oh well right when you walk in there's
the gt3 RS aligned with other Porsches
not that one cuz only one and then to
the right is all make clearance I mean
they had it ready to go then that
Ferraris Lamborghinis everything ready
yeah
anyways car's in the shop why my boy
Alex a shark works went dude we make a
dope exhauster I think he gets even
louder more horsepower lighter oh it
really goes fried you doing am I have a
good friend in Pasadena
now this isn't roads a poor shop who
installs on it cool I'll take it had to
do cool when can you do it he owes
Monday cool come pick it up they picked
up this morning I get it back tomorrow I
Paul you had to do it oh good the
problem with you is this is Jay is so
proud this is it this is a guy who can't
say no it's he's doing blow and somebody
goes I got the pure [ __ ] listening this
stuff is no but when we flew this down
time to party when I pull up to the
Comedy Store on when I get on Thursday
and I had a set there I'm rollin show
run goes where do you go from here now
you got won't do for now
what are you gonna do now video for me
where do you go this is it I mean I'm
yet other cars but you want hang it this
one appreciates in value yes so this one
if you bought it three years ago would
be you know it's worth significantly
amount more that's that true yes it's
well the only cars that does that why is
that just the naturally aspirated the
type card is the rarity the what goes
into the car it's a [ __ ] team so so
we're you know busy I'm not losing
behind the wheel of this car well nobody
it's the ultimate ultimate Porsche it's
the first Porsche made it a street-legal
race car it's the first like
street-legal race car now with the
Porsche engineering yeah and let me tell
you something those seats no see that's
comfortable not comfy well I looked at
them to my back hurt yeah yeah but do I
look good yeah yeah I looked at the
seaso my feet hurt sometimes and Yeezys
yeah yeah don't wear em yes you'd rather
look good and feel good yes
do these tight jeans make sense not
really
like the way I look you can't help it no
you can't help it okay let's see
ultimately if you're like you won't see
any pricks driving on La in this thing
cuz too much of a car and they don't
know what it's like how much for that no
I'll go with the turbo cuz I'm a dumbass
because they don't know I'll take it
easy if you know cars you ever hit this
but turbos a lot of cars more car than
you can drive you had to get you had to
go the new killer option I went up them
well I think we're playing pogs I'm
dropping the big it's
chitty-chitty-bang-bang on [ __ ]
steroids it actually flies yeah might as
well fly so it's got a jet engine in it
can I may I ask you do I want to get
into psychology of this J Saab is so
happy with me but but you you you
there's a thing inside of you where you
go they go look we have this car but now
we have this car this is a street-legal
racecar here's the thing we know you
can't really open it up so you go I
gotta have that kind of power under the
wheel why yeah I gotta have it you know
I invited me to talk to a therapist no
this is common for people who love cars
yeah that's true it's like like like Jay
sent me all these articles how it's the
best car on the racetrack and it sets
all these records on it that's fantastic
yeah I know how this is gonna help me
going on a bit Kenny but thanks for
sending me that right it's just like the
potential I guess yeah it's like with
watches I can get a Casio that tells
time yeah I'll tell time yeah it's about
what goes into the Rolex what goes into
Bitsy's Oh some people some people get
guns up that collect cons why in the
back of their mind here comes well Devon
zombie apocalypse they got this I got
this
so sometimes you're you're motivated by
a feeling of fear or safety or whatever
it is and we know that there's human
impulses should they say human beings
can never have enough security
they love security right that's
different that's speed and power see
you're the fastest guy wrote it but it's
also a pity I don't drive I don't drive
like an [ __ ]
now I've been with me you're like dude
speed up yeah you drive to be in them to
me also it's a what that car represents
in the rarity of it you're not gonna see
anyone else with it
okay here's my question but here's the
other thing and I said this on
below-the-belt I and I was when I was
driving in in my fantastic uber driver
as a who's defending Bill Cosby that's
another story anyways when I was coming
in I was thinking myself because it's a
fine line cuz I don't
wanna brag and say no look what I bought
flashy like Floyd Mayweather something
like that but at the same time and I
have this this chart in my in my office
where I have goals and I said if I hit
these two things I'm gonna do something
if I cuz you know you and I both tear
what we never celebrate stop and smell
the roses not so I said if I hit these
two things yeah I'm gonna get this cuz I
know those two things what it means and
I'm gonna dis my dream car and hopefully
Jay can find one that exact color I want
which happened so if I hit these two
things season two below the belt and
Showtime and this other thing which is
even bigger than that if I can get those
two things greenlit this is what I'm
doing with it right that happened and
then just the perfect storm so I like to
me it's not like I'm not posting saying
oh look how much money I have to me it's
like the when we started this yeah for
example when you and I started the show
I had nothing brother
I get emotional when mom when we bought
shirts I had to borrow money from Brian
I think maybe we should do these find
the kids shirts
he was let's do my dude it's two grand I
don't have time I don't have two grand
and Brian goes here's two grand sold the
shirts so when it remember I was
fighting I couldn't do any of this stuff
not even now yeah you didn't know where
you were going I was broke but what I
had was a mic and a voice and the best
friend who we went down this journey and
so did everyone else on this show so now
it's like check out what we did guys
yeah check out where we came through
well that's what I thought I thought to
myself your dad always loved Porsches
always always and you grew up with the
idea that there there was a dream car
because you loved cars but mainly
because it was it was it was a real
quantifiable marker I mean you're
actually not a materialistic guy it's
not like you go oh no different now I
feel no different but it is a nice
marker to think that you never could
have thought about affording a car like
this no way no like I said he's my
brother got emotional talking about it
through even through tax yeah I went
King he goes can you he goes five years
ago when you were fighting six years ago
can you imagine if I told you you're
gonna buy a gt3 RS I went the [ __ ] yeah
see I don't know what yeah that's crazy
I don't know
kid the ultimate car was at 9:59 which
are like two million dollars now but it
was a 959 Porsche this is the equivalent
of buying that now Jesus that's why I
post about it yeah I know that's fair
because I like I feel like like when I
fall people they post something like
damn that's inspiring man that's dope
like they had a goal they achieved it
through hard work and through a lot of
help you know I'm saying
and then my acting teacher it's
different than posting stacks of cash or
[ __ ] you know there's a girl who used
to who was my acting class and she was
struggling struggling she got a job it
was a big deal but it wasn't you know it
wasn't like a lot of money and he said
she goes I was looking at these cars and
it was just the first time I could even
afford a car and I was gonna get them
more leather seats but I you know and he
said get the one with leather seats and
she goes it's a little he goes I don't
care
get the one with leather seats and
figure it out because it'll make you you
deserve it like it's a marker yeah like
it's it's it'll make you feel [ __ ]
better and you'll feel like more of a
star yes sometimes when you assume the
position yeah I know you're not a car
guy starting I don't really text you
during car she's like what the [ __ ] do
whatever you want it's I don't take you
but I text rogen my dad and my brother
and then D'Elia and it was unanimous
anyone's like get the [ __ ] car I'm
like all right all those people are
pretty good pretty close to me and then
I emailed my business Paul yeah Anthony
I do as he goes get it like I'm alright
yeah so awesome I could if I didn't if
my wife didn't have horses I could get
you could get four of those yeah after
that four so but she has horses so you
know we don't take him out I don't want
you to kill the horses bro yes I do it
no that's a hard thing to kill those
would be so hard to kill
yeah horse is tough twelve hundred
pounds try that you need to go you need
a rifle force to be tough or on my jet
they have you ever seen Apocalypse Now
when they're killing the bull oh please
get this Harley
Wow classic movie I was [ __ ] crazy and
they're really doing it they're actually
killing out like just shoot like a
Apocalypse Now how long do they shoot
that for it and weird that where did
they shoot it
that there's a documentary on it called
hearts of darkness and it's engrave you
seen that documentary no oh my did they
shoot answers for Coppola a Thailand sir
so Thailand and it shot for how long and
they were using choppers and there was a
war next door and they had to use the
chopper so in the middle of the shoot
France for clothes where the tailor
choppers they need it for the war you
should see that it's how real it is he
started going crazy I've seen Apocalypse
Now but well I've never I've never seen
that documentary my point is is doing a
little bit of movie that I've done if
you're not set all day in cowboy boots
for 14 hours I thought well I'm in South
Central LA there's a trailer there what
if not stuck in the Shia LaBeouf and
goes the I should see more we were on
the set of fury and where the [ __ ] they
were Poland for six months on it oh that
would be terrible
yes sir I would Oh sir and please
understand
Martin Sheen had a heart attack while
filming had a heart attack in the
cardiac arrest yeah and did booze and
drugs to play the part where he's losing
his mind you should see the [ __ ] you
have to see it a goddamn what's it on
Marlon Brando didn't want to be shown so
because he was fat and he was insecure
so they decided to shoot him in this
light yeah like don't also didn't really
know the lines and there's one part was
doing the lines going
[Laughter]
I'll give you young Harrison Ford please
go back to that oh my god about that
dude laughter after being on set again
just for one day this is my movie
experience just for one day on a major
movie after Brad said one day I called
you and I went I can't believe did this
for so long I can't see it being in your
Navy I don't put this week your dream
when you move to LA was to be a working
actor which you are but is the Goldbergs
not like that's not like hurry up and
wait is there now it's just TV no it's
TV but movies still waiting I'll be
there
12 hours a day yes I'm doing the Joker I
was offered a part I'll be sick that'll
be fun but I think it's only a couple
days I'm playing an aging dancer
male stripper I can't go into the detail
but just know that it's gonna be good
and I hope my psoriasis is a flaring I
just can't imagine like being on set
what's that you being on set oh my god
I give way to 5:00 in the morning and
we're just hanging around what I did
right along me and John Leguizamo we're
in our trailer for four days we legs
giant legs and I didn't go anywhere we
just stayed for a shot and we read plays
together and we hung out and they sing
clapping that's correct sir and you're
you're not anywhere you can go you're
you're in all the band and really get
familiar with people very fast you do
like being around all day and just
center line clear with you better like
he worth and then sometimes you're on a
movie where the person stays in
character like Daniel day-lewis and
you've had some experience with this and
there's you're not hanging out and
they're just in character the whole time
I would go rate lost I would go crazy
you would have to love the gig you'd
have to love these yeah the fact that
you're now now your adds the fact that
you're a Christian Bale and you're also
not eating you're also not eating sir
you're just skinny so they're like why
did you do that he goes well I put
makeup on and I make believe so I have
to do something manly mm-hmm it's it's
fascinating to me like the it's crazy
it's crazy yeah would say about brand
another in the Patriot you paid three
million dollars for a month's work and
even only work on weekdays the weekends
they paid him well he didn't like acting
Brando was done with acting he thought
it was a silly endeavor and he wanted to
change the world stupid but um yeah I
talked about but he wrangled Colin's
trailer to talk about random topics that
I you gotta see the documentary hearts
of dark I have to know yeah yeah I need
go back well I've seen that movie in
forever yeah what's the fun of set
you've ever been on be like finding the
kid 3d you know I love the hangover sets
cuz I knew all those guys that's Radley
and yeah you know I get why Adam Sandler
does that thing where he makes all his
friends cuz they're going on the you
know the shoot all over my family and
then they're all they all grew up
together so all the kids know each other
brilliant what he's doing now you get it
like oh you're not making art why would
you just do after Lobby Madison makes
sense now the old production company
correct correct yeah you you you will go
crazy after a while you know Mel Gibson
was one time was talking about that on
an interview were like he's away from
his kids he had six kids and he was away
from them and I start to go crazy so
he'd bring them bring his wife and kids
with him yeah there's no other yeah that
kind of strange yeah yeah oh cool
picture Brian three guys at dinner
oh cool picture Brian three guys at zero
times oh cool Brian skipping the street
with a dude at dinner there's some
there's some stuff I have to address
here you got us good thing do you think
you showers Bluebeard Luke's want to
grab my goddamn hand I was like all
right I know buddy think then you gave
tark your phone told him to film it no
it didn't look the way I'm skipping my
skip is way better
he's tight man he's very tight yeah we
just wait said Scott that makes sense
then where you guys at Via Veneto you're
at scope a that was where we had a good
pot I went to scope uh Thursday or
Wednesday night Thursday night with the
Showtime guys I went to scope inv Havana
to this weekend oh this but back to back
if you want to find me I'm at scope or
have you have an entire universe not
home and I'm just usually he was eaten
yeah yeah the boy I love doing is oh
look it's through the exact same guy
[ __ ] booyah hey shot a special
Montrell hey dude I got this from Clea
actually uh I get I got a picture of a
check and his watch
his Rolex yeah like that did he buy it
he just bought that or something yeah I
can all my friends are [ __ ] I
totally get the gold one but he decided
to go with the silver what is that what
kind of what is that same as Glen but
his silver Oh
without the date so I get it there's a
big cheque here and and he's putting his
hand next to it he goes hey look at my
new watch
another special other books baby have
five now how many do you have
I'm only 38 though
[ __ ] you I take my time he goes speaking
of times you see my watch
I carry because you're the one I
mentioned time I'm like I'm not I'm into
Buddhism he goes trust trying to relate
I go I wasn't talking about your [ __ ]
you need you're not trying to relate
you're boasting I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Lilly's God he's obnoxious I hope he
closed the woody this line they did last
time I saw at the cabbie store I was
[ __ ] dying
you just think I'm gonna use as my
closing right please do it it was so
good little monster a little monster how
much RAM pretty crunk about that firing
the kid well that's picture me dude you
know I don't see enough Thompson girl
whenever I see him at the comic store my
eyes go dude I know he's got a baby
they're their new baby somebody know
about Tom car guy big car guy really big
car guy
you don't say he just said he is a is a
not a gt4 here's a came in and he just
sent his to get all souped up times like
I just I love Tom I didn't know use that
beaver car guy
he's getting a a things you know em too
but he loves cars you knew all about my
car sat in the car and em - what's name
- you don't it like a em forest or m5 m6
it's the smaller version he likes small
cars well they I did my brother like
like real car drivers like small cars
yeah some people think like the Boxster
like the think the box is like the best
pure Porsche because you know mid mid
engine I'm not smart a small card a nice
for so I'm out m2 we have them eww where
I hear the BMWs coming out with an
electric car I could Tesla do you mean
Porsche Porsche Porsches yeah Porsches
yeah it's supposed to be the tesla
killer yes Porsche 100 Tesla you make
cars very cool do you know what forever
kind of [ __ ] on your sales
that's the m2 I'm not into little cars
but the point was is I don't see Tom not
for left Tom I would use podcasts yeah I
might be driving a Porsche an electric
poor soon if I'd be really expensive
that right
yeah those camp they're not giving those
away sure we're a little bit out
specially it looks like that's like this
that'd be amazing
well yeah it'd be amazing and be with G
Gillian dollars you know Tesla very cool
let's try this out good kink yeah I was
pictured me and Tom and Santino I like
Andrew I know bro
he's blowing us off that's in T no no he
keeps blowing us off I'm dying up here
and then how about some so some fan sent
that art to the fire and the kid that
yellow in the Batman Robin art yeah
and then as Theo von as the Riddler as
Chris D'Elia as the Joker has Bobby Lee
as the penguin the new me and as Batman
Robin like and we're gonna make that a
shirt I love it but I was worried cuz we
had to get the okay from all those guys
yeah use their name and likeness self
your friend sharing him son shirts why
would you make that why don't we do
another shirt a special edition with
Rogen as the penguin what let's just use
his likeness and not ask him okay how
about Brogan is Bane and the newest
Catwoman look at wait she doesn't do
that but that's how how graze that sure
that's a good meow but that one's don't
do that bro hi friend
hyper friend and all your furry oh yeah
why do I have a [ __ ] now I'm just
transgender superhero I think you know I
think they're gonna do a transgender
surveyor one in the comic books didn't
sell very well so enjoy that
god damn oh that's uh that's Halle Barry
Barry yeah she's so [ __ ] hot yeah
still smoke shows mm smoke show mm bro
killing it Catwoman is hot
the ultimate Catwoman was Eartha Kitt
she was incredible not Michelle Pfeiffer
was
ask that one or two quick arthur kid
back in the day the original cat won't
be tally baby though arthur kid doesn't
let me see yours the case below tonight
that's right I go back dunk it
ki TT she was amazing singer singers
badass beautiful look at Arthur kid take
it easy
oh cool hey it's your Romero's temple
too bad picture change it oh cool man no
that dude oh dude so much Halle Berry
oh yeah Oh check it out everybody she
was a cat oh cool it's Diego Brando is
Catwoman that's fantastic watch your
[ __ ] mouth bottom cap no doubt bro
you're out she had a strong get older
you just [ __ ] get a strong yeah when
you lose all touch of reality this is
what happened she had a strong she had a
strong power Oh Louise Ortiz as Catwoman
that's fantastic
hurry up Louise Ortiz now they have the
exact same he had a strong job I'm not
gonna bring up Ortiz film on come on
dude they look identical you
[ __ ] you want to see here his
Catwoman lied oh that's so [ __ ] up oh
do they not look identical and they do
have a similar they could be brothers
similar lips nose yeah they can be
brother and sister
he looks like Luis Ortiz Halle Berry
[ __ ] that ends this one
[ __ ] that's fine caddies a badass she is
not gonna be a weekend no oh my god he's
some poor cat down Phil McNasty style
you might be able bring it up chin but
she's knocked out and it is [ __ ]
horrifying there it is there it is hold
on Bobby
that's my shotgun um what's this return
fight highlights what if the
there's some guy from a cellphone
there's nothing better chin
this is the first one he clicked on do
me a favor no doubt uh let's see I'm
sure there'd be something I felt it it
for today says it was this let's do this
week you don't have to have today though
rasa
there it is parties son show time Jim
Shabbat seems big this guy's a for this
this is happening now
filthy this must have hurt so bad here I
will bite you just watch this oh Christ
that's it down the Jews now watch how
[ __ ] up he is the phone he's like now
I got it's good it's all good
straight left son from [ __ ] Cuba good
lord
nasty right such a good love people
didn't see that yeah that's his last
fight since he fought Wilder Wow who was
that guy he fought obviously a killer
Roz Roz von Koch a new Russian guy
Cochin you boom there it is yeah she's
yeah good wilder he's been to well he'd
knocked Wilder now if I remember
correctly right he did not come down you
sure look at that is that over like long
hook water's wobbled like a [ __ ]
look at that perfect positioning oh my
god oh and he pulls right back out look
at this look at that what a nasty ha all
right Jen damn Oh cuz yeah there you go
there's your Catwoman unbelievable she
could box here yeah box these nuts in
her mouth
you be respectful of the great Eartha
Kitt is she alive No
she was a great singer cabaret singer
not bad a real actress not a real
actress though back in the day - I'm not
a lot of work with black women
oh she's pretty who is that caddie Julie
Newmar I don't know her she was she from
that and Wes seriously yeah I must be
it's great that Adam West series was as
I loved it oh my god credible actors and
all hilarious she was cute
oh [ __ ] on her though yes she is a fox -
stone cold fox bro yeah look it's
wasting paste they keep bringing her up
chin don't hate oh that's all out of
west person put it down
Oh they said Adam West's mouth I work
with Adam West's Batman and Robin [ __ ]
much loved his women I worked with him
wasn't as great I spent a week with that
[ __ ] I loved him I loved him go to her
when she's in that far right there chin
second one in third row down the one
where she looks all right that great
that's her older so how old is she this
she's got him 100%
dude the top left Creek out the top left
one you see it where she's older or the
old one yeah okay we had her older man
she's smoked Wow I mean such poise what
a woman do this remind me of old
Hollywood I was watching my favorite
show right now the dark tourist damn dog
look at her hard to go that's that's the
Joker there know the through the Joker
that's the Riddler the old-school
Riddler that's a crazy old man doing up
hurt it's got anybody counters you start
to you know man yeah you're right when
you're right right big dick energy but
on dark tourists they go uh this episode
I think it's the last one episode 8 they
do the Charles Manson tour which I
definitely want to go on they go to all
the sights and then some guys on the mic
tell me what happened they played things
man I'd like to see it but I don't want
to be a bad person contribute to that
yeah but also the
had a guy on there that is when Charles
Manson died he left all his [ __ ] to this
dude who's just a fan he left it all to
him so they go interview this guy one
who died
Charles Manson died in prison right oh
he's still alive no he's not Charles
Manson
did he die hey hon I got a call yeah no
he's right here it's John 18 you [ __ ] he
did that it god damn it no this year
last year oh we thought we talked about
we put his music remember right anyways
he died in prison quite some time ago
and so they Lincoln this is that
gentleman there on the right they linked
up with a dude who was his best friend
and they met in prison and there but
there he also talks you guys who they
think Charles Manson is their hero and
but they're not like you know not for
murder and like he's yeah II didn't kill
anyone bro that's Oh everyone says he
actually kill anyone bro
we did nothing he just ordered it but
even then they can't prove that
however he off see was the manipulator
of this whole thing and why people died
they actually did kill so not this style
but he did shoot people that they know
that for a feel so it was purposely
trying to start a race war and
orchestrate it all because he wasn't
famous he's whole thing was to be famous
and I thought he was just misunderstood
and all this stuff but anyway so this
guy relates to him they become best
friends as picture him in prison
Charles Manson leaves all stuff to him
and so this guy goes into his house to
interview with them and the guy gets
super offended like it's an argument
because he's like you know asking about
how can you like this guy and how can
you say he's doing these good things the
guy starts to defend him he gets pretty
gnarly
Wow it's a good [ __ ] show man this is
my favorite episode this is the Jeffrey
Dahmer one horses for rent 869 yeah well
a lot of people have a bunch of Manson's
old [ __ ] like where the murder scenes
were out there you can buy stuff and
it's creepy [ __ ] you see these best
friends with Charles Manson and
so-and-so he gets down they shoot this
area it's like the day transmittion dies
like the next day he was how you doing
us how would you feel if your best
friend [ __ ] died he's all what well
yeah come on you live relax first of all
first of all did they'd serve time
together no he was a fan of rock I'm
Rotem 50 no others on how they're the
same
[ __ ] and how they connect weird oh
yeah you're a weirdo pretty and figure
into murder uh yeah it's some dark [ __ ]
so should we hair out the murders went
down is that is there boy they what the
[ __ ] it was his name the main dude tank
or will affected hope the terrible dude
well those guys mess for all the
imprison right he was also batshit crazy
Tex Tex was the guy he was batshit he's
crazy he's good him Tex Watson Tex Tex
is the one who did mostly old crazy man
he's the bad one okay yeah he's those he
did all the killing yep he was the bed
looks like a killer he looks like
someone's dad there yeah yep
Tex Watson alright yeah bad people but I
was telling chin I was at the Justice
which Lane sir I was at the Long Beach
aquarium and some dad told another dad
to get his son cuz he kept squirting
people I said there's do you want a sure
way to get in a fight correct someone
else's kid on parenting or a painting on
parenting and it's [ __ ] on man like
fisticuffs weird I just settled these
two down yeah you did yeah because it's
this kid was squirting other parents and
I think that means kids it's hot as [ __ ]
outside you were in the line of fire of
the water and this guy Turner goes brawl
the dad goes did you just call my son
bro you serious right now oh no you
think no dude dude is just call my son
dude and then they've got into it called
was a kid six or seven take it easy but
there's one way you want to get a fight
till someone da parenting is ratchet
correct my son my school said hey dude
and this mom goes how hetero of your son
how hetero of him she was dude how
hetero you know I just said shut up in
yeah exactly what the [ __ ] are you
talking about British a dog really makes
me angry my wife asked me if I wasn't
there my wife cuz I'm glad you weren't
there I said yeah you are cuz I would
have said some [ __ ] oh my god get your
[ __ ] ideology out of my [ __ ]
face that's crazy man yeah don't [ __ ]
judge my kid and make him feel weird for
saying something nice to your son you
ask what do you say just what's up
dating Tom you say what's up dude you
said hey dude
do what that's what we're dealing with
okay yeah that's one party so dumb
were you hit as a kid when you yeah
we're at a place like slapped my mom
your mom or your dad
come on took a belt in the riding crop
to the legs that's all it's good by the
way do I deserved it mm-hmm okay weird
love people do the my dad never had me
my mom was like I can't do funny that I
remember I realized my brother's crazy
because my dad did I made start laughing
one of us is crazy angry every try dad
problem I remember my mom came home
after one time smacked my brother and
her hand hurt she was Peter this is
before their door sheis I don't know
what to do I hit him she laughs I can't
him hard enough laughs it off he knows
what he's doing
this isn't working it's not [ __ ]
working my brother's just smiling like
you psycho bro yeah cuz that [ __ ] hurts
well you would do it because you're more
sane would go oh you're gonna hit me and
you think that's gonna work well I'm
gonna pretend like it feels good every
psycho every child said college now no
matter who they are would be like
hitting your kid is the worst thing but
there are a lot of cultures that do and
I mean if we called work and I don't
know like I read books I read these
articles where I see some let's say it's
okay to certain like my kid I've never
either but and then I see other articles
where like get down on their level
talking like a human like you ever try
talking a three-year-old like a human
like you try to get down their level
they don't really understand it there
are ways to establish boundaries and
there are also ways to establish
consequences so now my wife won't be
like this she'll be like she like you
want to keep doing this okay cool just
know there are consequences and then
it'll be time for her to do something my
daughter oh she wants something I don't
my well I know I wanted to but we're not
gonna do that today remember yeah remote
yeah and that that goes a long way so
she knows she's not as old he's right my
wife a reads the books she's smart about
it me I lose my [ __ ] I just start
yelling around like
yeah yeah and my kids call me on it my
what my daughter the other day I got mad
at my I threw a tantrum at my wife and
my son was there or something I was and
I whatever I give I go my daughter comes
walking back and she goes you need to
come out and apologize and I go what and
she goes you're 51 and I think it's time
you act like it oh wow I went oh come on
she grabbed him by the hand well and she
walked me outside of my wife is there
and she goes mommy daddy has something
on sale no B would you say your wife has
three children in the hell she does I
don't know how she doesn't kill you
imagine a war she doesn't I go and I was
like sorry am i what my daughter goes
she couldn't hear you you know you know
something my daughter was back in my
daughter was right my daughter was right
do you think your smiles on your
daughter
that's the Michelle with the true shape
the answer is yes the answer is yes it's
gonna be very hard to break to my family
that I'm a gay as well I've done as dumb
John went out in the long run about on
my below the belt on how dude you know
I'm into now you know what I care about
most these days watering my lawn
I love wander my lawn I love that it's
green it's funny how as you get old an
old burro yeah when you get older also I
don't like messy stuff like I see stuff
on the ground and I pick it up oh yeah I
used to not care I know me now like
order like my car has moves this your
house like before I was like renting or
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] they did a
thing we wrote mez men get older your
brain gets more organized like men care
about little things like they tend to
want order it's something that as you
get older you want you want more
predictability so if this [ __ ]
everywhere like my dog took a giant [ __ ]
the core you know the German our Germans
ever decided to take a a giant an
elephant's eye shed on my very expensive
rug got all that [ __ ] I lost my [ __ ]
I lost my [ __ ] so did he yeah I went
crazy I had some bad ever since I was a
kid man I've loved grass I used to have
a moment when I was 13 out of own
business my friend Joey I created cards
with jet George Jetson on it said Mon
company brand and Joey's Mon company
passed cards out I just loved him
lovegrass really trimming I can smell of
it love the smell of it reminds me of
when I was a kid I love the smell of
grass I love except this morning lon I
judge everyone on lawns
that I don't know is a cartoon is one of
the options on there so I picked George
Jetson doesn't make sense
that's not to do from mowing lawns we as
a kid though that made Bank and then our
buddy who was he was our age but he was
for whatever reason he got a hold of a
truck with a thing so we started to open
up to different suburbs making $20 in
lawn for more kids all that raw it's
really good to turn a day you like it
maybe go maybe for mow four to five
you're outside all day and my headphones
on my shirt off sick pretty cool get
yourself a nice little tan yeah but I'll
I'll and then we [ __ ] play football
night or [ __ ] movies that's such a
good childhood man dude I just love long
arcade and take so much pride with water
my ficus isn't [ __ ] I went there Kade
with my son's birthday one which one the
Santa Monica Pier and we went the arcade
with my daughter my son they were
playing that on the pier they're laying
out Walking Dead thing where you kill
zombies with the guns yeah that thing's
fun holy [ __ ] my wife got crazy into it
you know what it sucks for kids though
because they're never gonna experience
their arcades like we did as well like I
did you were playing [ __ ] know I
remember arcades did you oh yeah we had
a place called at Latins where that the
the dark night shooting happened you see
it was right by there's called Aladdin's
they had the dopest video arcades my dad
drops off there give us a few bucks and
we were there for hours but yeah they
had like Street Fighter and Tekken and
all the dope ass games you could play
non-stop Mortal Kombat it was sick man
kids now today the game boy or I'm
certain hook game boy Jesus Christ they
had lad and baby but they're like ps4
Xbox those arcades can't compete those
[ __ ] on them graphic wise you have it at
you at your home you don't go to our
kids anymore our kids are dead like
there was a boardwalk USA where I was at
that's [ __ ] great man now kids just
have everything at home it kills that
I'm old enough to remember when Atari
came out with pong yeah by the time I'm
old enough to remember when pack
man was the rage and we're a hotel
asteroids was huge to centipede all
Tetris all that contra left-right
left-right up-down up-down a be okay sir
I wasn't good at him well you just got a
plan bro
yeah contra hands down best game all
time Brian take a hike why go over all
these video games contra don't remember
it no you you're pregnant twenties or
thirties I went playing it you're a kid
Mortal Kombat marineo B you played a lot
of video games [ __ ] yeah really [ __ ]
yeah well you don't play them anymore a
lot of guys keep playing them no I don't
play me you got no time yeah no time but
as a kid like we would play them but we
were outside all day then at night we
play that or we play that for an hour
but then we were outside sports yeah we
was like we play but ooh doom Mario
World
like what was yours where were your
sports besides football when you're
outside famous sport name any sport with
a ball everyone
name one yeah play basketball behind
slop
yeah played baseball non-stop we played
everything all the time were you gonna
FaceTime today yep sure was and the
cross yep
we played all sports all day anything I
would drink fill up with coca-cola and
keep on keep on
I would leave at night we'd get to the
courts at 9 a.m. and we get home to 7:30
p.m.
wow the kids can't do that these days
just play sports all day all day then
I'd have a few bucks me and my brother
and my friend Anthony Turner walk over
to 7-eleven refuel with oh I don't know
I sees maybe some Doritos maybe some
candy yeah hit the courts sweating yeah
is the best yeah nothing better I didn't
grow up that way play games at night
drop overseas had a great childhood
cruisin USA there arcade game God that
[ __ ] when you run everywhere on your
bike and [ __ ] everywhere
we lived I live right by Overland High
School where I went to high school so
there's fields everywhere and if and at
night we'd play in the streets what
about the wintertime you're in school
we're in school boy we'd we'd still play
football in the snow is great
[ __ ] yeah who's the best touch football
[ __ ]
no Brian no no I've never played touch
in my life never come on private school
[ __ ] College you guys like tackle in
there in the snow
yeah our favourite just a bunch of big
old bully boys number one time there's
an app there's like legit Snow White
whiteout snowstorm six feet of snow but
I wanted to walk to my friends house so
we could play football and play video
games so my mom was like yeah we'll do
or the [ __ ] you want to do cuz Pinterest
like yep you have to worry I can kidnap
back then and I watched all I don't know
three miles and the snow up to my
[ __ ] chest I was in seventh grade
dude you're dangerous that was it took
me hours to reach my friend's house then
our cell phones in like five hours no
cars come down the roads or if I got
stuck I know my mom like I figure it out
come on out crazy right I've never let
my son do that [ __ ] vodka I can't
believe my dad let me go on [ __ ] uh
spring are my senior trip how about the
fact this last time I tried to pick you
up well we were we were the last time we
did this is back in the day we did a
live fighter and a kid in Denver and it
was in the outskirts of Denver oh yeah
and I had to come get you and I'll come
get you in NJ and I was sliding all over
the [ __ ] place slidin slip-sliding
away crazy dim ringing you're pretty
crazy oh yeah I was like what is Claude
guy's black ice
gots to watch out for the black ice bro
that's shaking a racist yeah he's a
white ice begins okay chin you've been
around snow much I flipped on a black
ice you did in Big Bear you flipped
flipped my buddy's truck we're going
downhill yeah we're going down no for
like not even fast like 15 miles per
hour
there's a turn he turned the wheel and
we're still going straight and we're
like what's gonna happen hit the wall
flipped flipped on top the windshield
crushed on us I thought were gonna get
smashed to death and then it stopped and
then we started sliding down the
mountain my buddy jump all questions
don't one up his story brah
oh hey Trump's how about Charette but
did you did you get hurt one of our
friends did get
got thrown out of the truck file yeah he
wasn't wearing a seat belt house leap he
had his back injured and then he was in
the emergency room and we had like a cop
come down get us back up the mountain to
the emergency room so he was getting
checked out no injuries no but my friend
lost his shoes in the snow with Court
like glass everywhere and a bunch of
cars that came to that same area they
started sliding hit the car another one
hit the car no my buddy flipped his 19
years no Honda Civic and he goes and he
was acidic Oh boom flipped it right over
on his back and he got out and he was
like dude it was [ __ ] crazy
my taekwondo teacher same kind of thing
i in the snow boom boom boom he gets out
car hits him oh no he does sends him
flying he's in hospital for a long you
know lease it's a lot of ways people die
so you're gonna accent you get out of
your car and all that other cars don't
see coming on the highway and your
family people die that oh yeah we're
gonna came or let's say you're gonna
wreck and you stop your car and you're
in the right lane yeah and I pay
attention
they [ __ ] really and you die like
that that's why they say do not stay in
the car no I get it
I'll walk out if you can't get it off
that's so scary
y'all have gas I ran a gas with a rental
car in an Abe in dude and in a one of
those dodges in the left lane ran out
just stopped in the left lane you're
screwed my buddy goes let's get out we
get out hill jumped out and their cars
were just missing us just missing us and
then this a a guy trip lay guy he just
comes out one of those old road dogs
just lays down he just lays down flares
I didn't give a [ __ ] I was like these
you're gonna die you're gonna die and
it's a babies this Christman
that scares me I gotta get nervous
thinking about it Marilyn my Porsche
broke down yes a GTS broke down the site
because something came through the the
ram air in the front and hit one of the
things and just shut down on me and I
was off to the side but [ __ ] man even to
the side I ran just got down that's how
you can stop that
Oh game over so sad
now that sucks I hit a mattress in this
BMW I bought I bought it I 535i or
whenever one of those like turbo like it
was a turbo I I the only test car it was
a big movie right okay 5:35 bye yeah
yeah 5:35 and it was his car things fast
I guess and I hit a mattress hit a
mattress and what happened to it
and I and I just boom I jumped over them
like I get it jumped over the max I
thought I was gonna wreck for sure and I
was in the highway going about 60 and I
somehow jumped over it dude I remember
when your was lower one but right back
in the day right b5 says those were cool
one yeah they're cool I remember uh
copper on that clop and I were going
down the highway in Denver and trucks
there all have chains on the tires yeah
most truck students in the middle of
winter but there's really no snow on the
ground and it was a huge semi we're
going 80 miles an hour down thing and
one of the chains breaks I see it for
Mike half a mile but not closer to half
a mile I see the chain break fly off and
headed straight for our car who misses
it by I mean the hit from hitting me in
the face and the windshield game over it
just like this did I remember we just
sat there in silence like oh my god
I was like dude if that's two inches
lower I'm dead Achtung my buddy was a
cop was a cop and he used to send me
video he'd just send me video they would
dude what a car would be flipping just
pay attention the cars the guy was perp
he had robbed a bank and shot somebody
he's trying to get away he flips his car
whenever the force was his head was
flying out and into the other opposing
lane traffic Paul lost his head another
dude jumped off a balcony to get away
from the cops and hit a fence like his
chin hit a fence and his head was neatly
mounted elite Lee mounted on the fence
Rose man
oh yeah oh yeah you being kicked in the
nuts yet you'd know wow I'm married now
people are gonna like walk dude you guys
like the wrong video video it's like a
dick cam said of a [ __ ] in with a dick
cam on and just some girl going yeah
yeah yeah this is a kick in the nuts
right his balls just purple ating yeah
just giant it just likes it getting
kicked right in here that's a weird
fetish I wonder where that happen there
are a lot over there my mother you still
I say anything you can think of has been
done and anything you can think of has
turned somebody on like just whatever
you can come up with I told you about
that really wealthy guy I knew he would
get into a big big plan container and
the women would fart in it yeah that's
cool he was in a fart chamber he'd be
stuck in this class and this big tube
that dudes a freak
you think he was very Pardo's when he
was I was rather aristocratic and very
rich Jim what are you doing this weekend
bro I'm going to my buddy's I guess it's
the opening for his complex studio
complex we're at at City of Industry
where's that Long Beach area laughs uh
so far it's not that far it's the place
I recorded that video where I was
singing oh nice yeah there's a bunch of
different studios so he owns it and that
he opens it up and rent the other spaces
he owns it and so does uh Adam Carolla's
producer Chris and then another one of
his buddies I think that's cool
yeah it's cool it's good stuff you just
go around there and [ __ ] listen to
beat and is there Drake they make music
right music that I write music with them
over there but it's his area it's his
stuff why do you forgive me
utilize she came to Austin dude oh yeah
big-ass crib out there for do you really
have a crib there yeah not mine but on
it has a cast there oh that would have
been fun maybe some other time huh yeah
yeah any current events j'en AI du by
the way your brother we're talking about
gross stuff your brother also texted me
that he has that same phobia as me the
little circles all over the place she
didn't promise sir Casca might swear
he's like dude I totally gay
the same fear or whatever feeling no it
doesn't ask him I guarantee no circles
of the little holes inside yeah let's
cutter together you ask him later
Tania he did so you're home flushing
bullets new to me alright so there are
write a song for us just FYI do what
dude kinda what do you got here oh my
god know what this is you do it good
I got a I'm not gonna play all of it but
so there's a video music video ah and
then if you guys know this girl she's
the cash male side girl well first of
all she's one of the biggest rappers in
the world now one the base YouTube stars
and our boy he'll bonds in her new music
video bye bye he's on a and it's been
out for I don't know has 7 million views
it's four days hit is I've seen it
battle game vo told me he was doing it
but I haven't seen it name is bad Bobby
you will love his character and this is
too bad baby is he funny in it or I
don't want to ruin it let's just uh you
watch it and then after that partner but
yeah she's a little kid she forced his
very own chill that's Tony again Phil
thank you I'm gonna tell you how she got
famous after this guy's she's not a real
rapper
oh my God look at the old thing hey did
they have casted it anymore had a foul
side but blue team he played really well
huh his face everyone everything looks
perfect yeah it's perfect it's a video
about being catfished I'm so into this
right now
and that's ty dolla sign yeah it was
also very huge very famous it's the best
thing Theo's ever done for sure yeah
100%
please tell me Theo tonin killer no look
at him or he's her dad and that's Bella
Thorne who is another huge song huge to
all they fooled each other yeah oh no
she's drugging everything she's drugging
I'm sorry this is serious [ __ ] it's all
right it's just like a she's just so
famous that it gets so many views
there's a knife
see it says pedo pedo oh and she's gonna
brand him right about yeah this is neato
or headies 4head oh wow wow that's dope
so he plays a pedophile make sense all
right Mike what if I've ever seen one
but did you know so that girl got really
famous cuz she was on was it Maury dr.
Phil dr. Phil and do you have that
original clip
I can't let me show you why this girl is
this famous she is Brian and it's gonna
make you sick because it's the age we're
living in now with Instagram and you
know and YouTube stars and stuff like
that 14 years old I know I don't
she might be 17 or 18 but so she was 13
when she did this so she posit for me
chin so she's on there because she's
being a hood rat she's out of control
so this launched her into being a mall
type she's richer than us
by far combines hey also wait how long
you been in she twenty years twenty
years five it's all very cool more
famous more famous hit it hit it chin
this is why Brian you ready feel sick
okay do you want her to be happy
yeah well she was cute where's your
father and all this do you know it yeah
was the last time you saw him have you
been hurt along the way there's somebody
your life hurts you those eyebrows hurt
I've taken advantage of you've done
something to you that she put up a tough
shell you don't it's like if I'm the
baddest [ __ ] on the street if I go
through life like this with my hands I'm
the baddest [ __ ] on the street get hurt
it could be a sense forty million bees
by the way Brian prepared to always be
but then she has to touch Bay where did
she go hood here pretty soon right we
try I hope so to go out and play the
role did she say catch me outside this
part I'm hiding in this clip
terrible so many great there's there's
no part of her doing catching outside
everything has to be Brian's way or no
way
Shoko after me like fights over like a
hit me she try to eat me and I got a
night Dodger and I she hates me I'm
giving it to her
well I'm pretty violent I'm wish during
the face kiss you and get out of my face
either I'm breaking down her doors what
do you say to yourself that gives you
the right to take somebody well
nonetheless she got famous from seeing
itself the influenced by the the urban
atmosphere
you know she's playing a character it's
very tough it's very much filling but
but it's just it's a giant it's a giant
she's a kid who dead who yeah no I know
but when you say hey don't do that
doesn't end well well then there's this
girl goes ah Dickie give you don't say
yeah I got a real help because my other
watch jeopardy in it but we live in a
time when if the lenses on you for a
long enough time it you can parlay that
in anything you have enough eyeballs
electical yeah I mean the wire but this
happens she's an overnight success yeah
she's also somebody though is hurting
she's also somebody who is probably when
I watch somebody who's putting on a
persona like that it coffee she's a good
actress she's a good actress she
complained she Cara Lee character
yeah and that's actually a form that's a
talent you know what I'm saying like she
she is a very good actress she's she's
able to impersonate somebody and she's
doing that out of necessity or whatever
but you can you can translate that into
anything she could be a you know you can
turn something like that into a good
actress no 14 million followers how old
is she I just do me nuts and in that
picture down there offer music view does
she post picture of Theo for me she does
I'm like you're a whole lot more hurt
the top one for god sakes
with the music video yeah oh there's no
ulti
in the back you should tag him though
who is actually tagged do ya sick that's
awesome that's dope
good forty oh man I'm worried they just
like Katie working for a pedophile my
softy like your at 15 years old so yeah
be careful on the cover about the way
she looked yeah it's a salt brother but
she said like the people the people in
the crowd and dr. Phil's audience are
like saying stuff about her she's like
catch me I'll catch him outside like
catch me outside half two minutes like
that is a phrase that just blew all of
the catchment outside girl calculus I
did catch my side then and then that way
and now she's like how she she
ridiculous there's good attention
there's bad attention here's the thing
though culturally tried I don't know how
she is as a person I've seen those don't
dr. Phil thing she looks like a [ __ ]
however now this what this young lady
who else he has some issues and it was
been hurt by whatever family issues she
has is has millions and millions of
dollars do whatever she wants now so
maybe that brings her happiest she'll
have to worry about being broke or find
a career now she's found it maybe she's
a better person now or she may or she
may complete [ __ ] war or she's she
has a lot of intelligence like she she
is somebody who was able to keep that
composure keep that character not be
intimidated by not crying but I didn't
cry over she's tough there's a giant
spirit that that very well may if
harnessed properly could turn into an
artist did you know something about that
we look at there's something about her
that she was able to hold that [ __ ]
together
and her name's bad Barbie right baby the
way she dresses all that [ __ ] so she's
very but she's beautiful there's also
that she knows what she's doing here
uh-huh and and oh by the way it takes a
measure of not apply or she doesn't
she's just she's only thing she's a
child
child well she does it but there's
something about her there's a discipline
to how she puts herself together other
people like yeah now could be a
sociopath
who knows but she seems to know what
she's good for her she figured it out
her dad is not in the picture but two
years now I bet you she's heard from her
father now she's worth millions and
millions of dollars be I'm sure that
came out the woodwork what else you got
Jim great colonel that so the guy that
one gangster escape by helicopter he's
still on the loose only got away he saw
this but they almost caught up to him
explosives ganks are spawning car with
explosive wow he got away
yeah so there's like a checkpoint
singular they noticed some the police
noticed like a car that looked
suspicious at a gas station and they
booked it so they left it as a shopping
center and apparently had like different
license plates in the back seat in the
trunk and it also had you know
explosives in a car it's nice oh yeah me
too he's telling us he's he got away
Wow see this gangster who broke out of
you see old footage of them in a
helicopter earlier that containing
explosives after being spotted by police
in a shopping center near Paris and when
they're doing a little piece on him he
looks for a botched robbery they can
hold an officer this was his second but
I handsome dude - what a stud [ __ ]
that's crazy
still on the loose gutsy guy okay Chris
Hardwick is set to return to AMC okay
after the investigation was complete
they felt that he didn't do anything
wrong
oh why because an old girlfriend cheated
on him yeah cheated on him now I don't
would it what he's doing the waist
controller that's not my style we don't
however let's say I'm just playing
devil's yeah okay let's say you and I
are two gay men Brian yep and I go hey
Brian I want to suck your dick and live
in your house you went cool yeah in
order for you to do that you need to be
home when I'm home and when I'm ready to
get my dick suck you suck my dick I hope
all right [ __ ] it let's do it yeah and
then I complain about it yeah
well no I signed up for the rules did
you hit me yeah no well not like that
how about the fact that she sent him
text seven months later hey you know
this is my fault
we should we get back together and he's
like no I'm good yeah so and then she
comes out with it okay and you yeah I
get my issue is I have to get this off
my chest
yeah do it personally when you do it you
for sure and what you're doing to with a
lot of this stuff is you're ruining
women who actually have real issue right
because this isn't a real issue well he
was degrading he did this whoa whoa whoa
walk the whole line I walked away which
is the easy thing to say you never know
what was going on there but also well he
expected this and he you wanted me home
cuz his busy schedule yeah you signed up
everyone wants a pit bull - you get a
pit bull then there's consequence of
[ __ ] with that pit bull yeah I mean
yeah that's how I I can hear the
pedophile talking next door deal Vons
next door impressive the pedophile I can
him from her face hey pipe down
don't fall I want if that's even stating
calls that's me you can hear [ __ ]
pedal next next event alright this is a
very like I'm afraid where this will go
but so this crazy guy yeah he's a white
dude just happens to be white and he was
in a train station a BART station yeah
in Oakland and he randomly hit up these
two sisters there happen to be black and
she sliced open one of the necks of the
sisters she died hold hold on let me go
back here random white dude we had a
criminal history so he come he comes on
the train there's two twin sisters or
just two sisters whose black sisters he
slices one in the neck yeah okay then he
just takes off and the thing is he has a
history he's like a he's a homeless guy
that's just ridiculous crazy this is
great crazy guy he's out of jail he's a
crazy okay okay what's the butcher's you
see them I see them all the time yeah
when they were they were protesting
violence what do you mean the bear is
were protesting just general those
sisters were no no
so anyways after this happened you know
there was this they made it like a race
thing a lot of you may like a race thing
and Anne Hathaway she posted on her
social media on Instagram I think she
was saying that people have to check
their white privilege and this is what
she says exactly so this is the girl
that was murdered unfortunately [ __ ]
Neil Wilson just randomly attacked and
then Anne Hathaway wrote something that
thought I think it's like overboard in
half way put the murder of Nia Wilson
may she rest in power in peace she was
denied here is unspeakable and must not
be met with silence she's not a hashtag
she was a black woman she's murdered in
cold blood by a white man white people
including me including you must take
into a mirror of our privilege bones the
truth that all black people fear for
their lives daily in America have done
so by generations
white people do not have equivalents for
this fear of violence given those Givens
we must ask our white selves how decent
are not in our attempt but in our action
hang on Anne Hathway first of all just
play [ __ ] cat will shut down the
elephants this has nothing to do with
white privilege I got a crazy man white
black green red right who found a victim
they have she's making black people
victims poor blind like you shut up stop
speaking for black people you have
[ __ ] dummy and what the [ __ ] cameo
but also that this this is a matter of a
crazy man yeah killed a crazy over here
you know what happens when I see this
stuff I don't see black and white I see
a crazy man killed a [ __ ] innocent
woman I don't go oh my god white man
yeah woman or if it was a black man
killed a white woman we're gonna sue
mitts race-related
no he's if it was a Chinese guy who
could like I would assume it's regulated
yeah no no and half the way went oh how
can I jump in so I get notoriety that's
like [ __ ] and forever let me do
something
mannish may she rest in the power and
you [ __ ] off and that was something what
do you talk it out of here Oh what the
[ __ ] do you know what would you know
about any of this
white people including me including you
must take into the mirror of their
privilege bones the truth that all black
oh good so and all by Bill fear for
their lives
in America do they and have done for
generations what are you talking about
this is my thing I agree whatever with
with black people in the DAF see at a
huge disadvantage every day walk around
different than white people that has
nothing to do with this this is a crazy
man got on a train stabbed this a woman
holding end of story
craziness with identity politics again
no it's an halfway clunky notes and hath
oh he's dumbass going how she's doing
this for a fake yeah she's doing this to
get notoriety to you attention exactly
to hopefully parlayed into some big role
that's all that's going on here
she what's about white privilege fusion
celebrity privilege here she's a dumb
dumb you're dumb dumb it was just
overboard I thought yeah just play
[ __ ] cat one do me a favor click down
here now thank you you know yeah here's
my least favorite Catwoman are you be
honest she's my least favorite generally
well she was really pretty I agree she
if you want to talk about fun to be
pretty and maple she want to talk about
train stop moping all right so this
fight at McDonald's is everywhere oh my
god you have you seen this for heaven
God I was just big woman get her hands
on you I would pay money to see her
wring your neck like this girl
watch this that's a big strong girl what
did you think that did you think that
the session Las Vegas the boy I thought
was gonna be in Hawaii sorry it's
already looks like hey bro why Hawaii
look at the girls Samoan I don't really
I'm not like Hawaiian I thought it will
beat up a small girl this is Vegas this
is Vegas McDonald's no they look they
look Hawaiian alright they're big nah I
don't
so there's on TMZ
yes you better be ready boy
oh she just tosses her on the table
and knock the coworkers trying to break
it up all right that little girls these
tumors are these the other ones have
blown out she's trying to attack the
co-worker that's trying to break it up
oh dear now they're going at it oh damn
look at these this holy [ __ ] that girl's
ganas she had with her son and tits
popping out
she must be hammer some let me ask you
this is the girl that woman works here
right the big girl look at this you grab
the chair is the other sister in DDT or
something I feel like that chairs not
gonna hurt her you better get a gun girl
and put your ass cheeks away so this is
a ride around at where it ends but so
the girl that customer whatever reason
was cussing at the the big girl and then
saying call her big fat whatever big fat
ass whatever and then at one point she
tried to steal soda from the soda
fountain by using a little water cup
then she try to sneak it by that girl
who has like she's like you can't do
that and that's when I started to
compete you know she kept going at
another big girl can't do I feel that
girl some fight in there oh yeah
these are the girls here looked into it
so does anything that's that girl this
is a customer
yes she is that by the way yeah nobody
know anything about it uh the one on the
right is the McDonald's worker and then
where's the other one I don't think the
other one just the two main ones so this
is the one that was the customer classy
lady dude she got her ass beat
yeah those big girls threw her around
like a [ __ ] ding dong correct like a
ding that she's this girl kind of
started she threw a my face gal in Vegas
like that yeah so let the girl get her
[ __ ] mr. pett or whatever the [ __ ]
this
let her get her mr. pepin broke don't
hate on her I I want to leave America
sometimes I'm just talking crazy about
my after that just the culture of
America does make you feel good about
yourself all the way around sometimes
I'm just like not go to Texas bro I like
Tex you get to Texas you
since I like I'll go to Texas live in
Austin the outskirts now you take care
your lunch money that one it's American
as it gets bro I don't mind that I don't
know man that [ __ ] doesn't get me down
that's chicken maybe no we we we are a
violent culture that's for damn sure am
i right about that
I feel like I'm missing to say were the
least violent we've ever been that's
true actually just it's more out there
now Instagram was back in the city 70
right by
that's all this actually true Oh some
chicken had to be able no they're
checking that cool but back in the day
we didn't have access ask would connect
even picked up book you're right let's
get you all right is a big see I'd like
to him girl much I would never think
that girl would go out like an orange hi
see I thought it was water
I guess she's wrong she had no fear
she's kept going on dude she got brave
about getting wrong [ __ ] paid
for them chicken McNuggets yeah was good
she bent her over yeah this one so that
Drake song that's having that makes
everyone want to get out of their cars
and dance to it in my feelings you see
these videos right so the NTSB which
stands for the National Transportation
Safety Board they sent out an official
warning for people to stop doing this
because of how many injuries it's
causing and see here's some of the
videos that they're showing of people
getting [ __ ] up it will get me yes oh
[Music]
her friends all laughing at her do heart
the first five cars moving way too fast
that's the problem no no that fan way
too slow here's another one
quick totally not a really dangerous man
you can get sucked under ah gummed up
what are you dumb it's going too fast
it's not athletic enough for the dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
you seen one this one like everyone
thinks it's the consensus best one
she's a singer she is so high saying she
shut it down it's on if you type in yeah
nope nope nope nope she's no on let me
find this beat this that one no nope
it's a black girl's curly hair light
skin let me see the white girl man
no keep going dude just why'd you type
in just a Kiki so we do a Kiki challenge
yeah Duty key challenge ID world star
per its prion world stars if you go to
world star we gotta find this scroll
down I shot at the world star yeah well
keep going yeah I know love this page
keeps growing find the sticky key
challenge no keep going we'll find it
here
I was looking at when I was in spoken
all spoke ants that's Mia wall it's
gonna be far down you probably do just
something that you see asses and wrap my
favorites let me see that one not a few
- gotta find go back we can go back yeah
we'll find it all right
still nothing how are you sure this is
this is what I promised it's on here
okay we're getting close guys we've come
too far
who's that guy with that face tattoo
that's six nine what a mess is it going
to be faster you see this grow hot oh
[ __ ] they must supposed to [ __ ] all this
stuff
oops brought did was that it screw-up no
it's a do go down alright you do a
strong Kiki still scrolling you might be
able to do uh how long ago got it just
an ass in there just all ass huh
yeah that's why I follow I don't see any
book recommendations on this so we just
go to challenge or still go oh let's go
up I see it is that something falling
out nope
keep going down whoa that looks like
someone's putting a plug ins on the
booty um I don't know chin I don't see
any Kiki challenge on their deal no
let's just try Kiki challenge and then
go ahead if we don't find anyone game
over alright
hashtag Kiki challenge hit this girl
first one that's a dang this one no
curly huh there you go right that's got
it there you go which one that one right
side problem jobs no skills a real
singer man
you know she doesn't look like a [ __ ]
alright alright not have to have Jason
it to us well [ __ ] a thanks for the
tees - I'm Sasha's cat i far the babe
I'm sitting on my hand on my pants I'm
exhausted
let's see the other one why isn't roast
kaitlin's what let's see that one go
back up I want to make sure everything's
okay with the other one the blood fine
go up - I hate I mean yeah let's just I
don't want to neglect the white girl I
mean I'll be there right there hey
that's straight up oh my god [ __ ]
differ sauce a crazy
yeah crazy hot no face not your style
chin just too much work done look at her
face and the car's not even moving
yeah that might be a Bentley or Mercedes
that's weird
yeah I've definitely never sleep with
her Brenda it's not all about sleeping
with somebody okay we can find a flute
I'm sad vici do you love me another age
maybe if you type in best stuff Kiki we
gotta feel like we should I agree I feel
like a bunch stuff but you know what
that's gonna be a [ __ ] let down bro
top ten no that's gone wrong top best
Kiki chance that's gonna be on there
he's gonna I want I it's it I built it
up too much and she's hot it's the best
one but it's not [ __ ] massive dudes
talk guys Oh what the [ __ ] she's hot
that's not her nope saw that one already
there's another dude I'm so disappointed
another look at her oh my God he's
actually good go back she can dance
especially Michael Jackson go down chin
is anything she's amazing
that's a real dancer right there no no
I'm so disappointed myself I can't find
it for you guys
maybe there's a screenshot we can find
it she doesn't exist maybe I'm making it
up you're a liar
Kiki all right do you know next episode
god damn it who sings that song it drake
name would be Drake
welcome to 2018 but I don't know Oh Kiki
chose good God well what is she doing i
lo all right we gotta move on from me
and Brian Jack off on every tree me and
Brian jack off it shows Mississippi
Missouri police on strike
oh yeah so this is an officer who was on
his phone making a turn and this
bicyclist is actually in the right lane
Nexen driving yeah
but also if your bike get off the road
keep going though oh wait
people use sidewalks anymore no they
don't go ahead and hit it though yeah my
computer's slow right now he has too
much cheese challenge poised off right
now
so there's the cyclist okay don't have
gloves on like that but I definitely
don't wear those gloves like that oh
there's no sidewalk so you gotta hit the
road like yeah I don't like that either
but we didn't do and this is like a
country road in Missouri sure so he's
stopping at the stop sign
they don't stop that long waiting for
traffic to see this win for cars to pass
by okay looking left and right cops
prowling for the key key challenge girl
like I was and hit him and there's a
common right now yeah so he's waiting
for the car he doesn't know oh this is
fun they're perfectly fine
yeah flip over this orange right into
him into his Lane not even like look at
your phone officer
the cop knows he [ __ ] up yeah what'd
the cops say he said he wasn't texting
he was looking at his phone
definitely that - either way a cop you
can't do that does the cop deserve to
lose his job I think he's just uh
suspended for now yeah
suspended for being all they got very
damaged plays the other breath where are
you why are you doing this is my bottle
dude so anyways he's all polite comes
down still no sir [ __ ] off sir like be
cool officer
it is tough I might want to shoot him I
that guy well just like if I'm going to
call them out I got it nothing personal
but you're already on the ground
I'm sorry you're not gonna live through
this anyway what'd you just say Hoosick
what haha dude your throw nice now that
knee does not look like it's gonna heal
it's obvious I put you down
I swear guys do that now but scratch on
my knee
in fact the douche you have rabies is
that it Jun do you want any more sure
sure
all right this one another one with two
cops these are female cops and they were
pulling over a woman for going too fast
but they didn't have an actual scanner
or anything so they couldn't prove it
the shy bald are going to Balder
wouldn't know once they bulldoze this
long enough these are the two girls well
the one the right looks like Marilyn
Manson one half is ain't bad all right
well anyways they pulled over this lady
and after they went back to the car they
were talking about like oh we don't have
anything to like prove it so they use
the app on a lot on the iPhone to flip a
coin to whether or not they're gonna
arrest you or not and it's just for
speeding so they arrested her for
reckless driving what this beating
I say and they went corded this
something body cam footage they weren't
thinking has cost two police officers
their job so they're not and their fire
and police officers Courtney brown and
Christie Wilson were fired Thursday
after they used a coin flip app to
determine whether or not to arrest a
speeding driver the incident happened on
April 7th long body camera footage shows
one of the officers questioning driver
Sarah Webb who was accused of driving
more than 80 miles per hour in a 45
limit zone that's fact officers has the
radar gun and therefore no definitive
proof so they assumed she was resorted
to the coin flip app to decide Webb
state but they decided to arrest Webb
anyway on charges of reckless driving
she was crying when she got arrested he
later dropped the charges citing the
coin toss a little obsessed but they
arrested her even though it sent a
release our lucky date for the drug no
they said heads release our tails
arrestor well I think this should lose
their job that's what sucks but to see
that's her crying right there well the
girls always cry [ __ ] I've seen so many
like my friends guys cry they all cried
it's scary but I mean for speeding
arrested have you arrest and put in the
back yeah like you're going to jail for
do ya know if you're going that fast yes
but the problem is they say 80 I bet
they're obviously exaggerating I assure
0-60 yeah I mean if you're going that
fast you do 100 miles an hour you're
gonna arrest yeah don't worry those
baggy shorts like that though when you
get arrested uh with the stretching all
right this is the last one you know this
woman kimberly guilfoyle
from fox you don't know you do know I
don't she's now dating Donald Trump jr.
and she joined the Trump the Trump team
that I'm gonna be careful here I'll be
super careful I'm not gonna even I'm
saying yeah yeah seven dates in another
that's not being very careful I'll be um
listen I'm trying to walk a very fine
line here not though cuz you're being a
very punchy read an entire pack of
bratwurst they don't know okay you're
being that's the biggest mouth ever
saying I can you know be a little more
can you be a little more subtle with all
right right grouper fish Brennan I bet
she inhales his car okay relax
first of all why why are these what
allegations of inappropriate behavior I
sexual misconduct think it was - by who
her well here showing personal
photographs of meet Janice Liza
colleagues let me get this straight
she's getting fired no so she left Fox
they thought she was leaving Fox for
Trump's whatever team but the reality
was shed allegations against her so they
think that she had allegations against
her sometimes I think there's a lot of
this going on she's connected to the
Trump's and there's so much hatred
hatred for Trump that people will do
whatever they can there's a lot of that
to that Matt I said yeah but she
actually left for the Trump know when
you're dating Donald Trump jr. you're a
target you say no I'm saying for some
photographs of male genitalia colleagues
in a pile of shells were a regular
discuss sexual matters at work engaging
most should be paid right sources said
that HR has been investing in her since
last year and gave her stern warning
yeah listen maybe she does show a few
dick pics of the dick she inhales
however yeah I'm sure it comes to light
now she's dating a truck and are we okay
and at work if I see a dick I mean are
we okay are we not I don't actually very
pretty she's very pretty yes she's oh
she's called she oh [ __ ] I died what
[ __ ] pic was did they show leave her
maybe they'll call she's hot man leave
her alone
jeez gorgeous so she showed some dick
pics get over it her mouth is four times
let's get the [ __ ] over it she might
have been abusive to the Harris tattoos
he is eight I don't know he's a nice guy
apparently
I heard he's nice too yeah apparently is
a really nice guy oh yeah who knows that
yeah I don't know
some people spend time with me too me
too for real
no I heard and he's a good guy and I've
heard that from a lot of people he's
never been a bad guy he's just got
scandal oh it's gone that's another
scandal no it's a dick pic scandal so
we'll just take pics I thought would be
Donald Trump juniors take but we are
living in a time n we are living in a
weird time and and you people like to
destroy the people's reputation through
that and I don't think it doesn't any
good I don't think it helps equality I
don't think it does any any good at all
I don't think it makes the world a
better place I think it's a form of
aggression and destruction I think it's
left versus right it's back to the same
source of [ __ ] be crazy you know that's
right we're going strong it's gonna
flare up if you don't focus on world
people keep asking me how this has
really been working for me this diet and
all people yeah it really has really
yeah like a remarkable see a doctor
really go see a doctor and he gallons a
doctor and and e-golf and swears by Dan
corner dan garner 88 at gmail.com text
him I mean email him if you have
questions about your psoriasis he's like
you see a doctor too though he's a
doctor I know I'm just saying but if
you're if if you don't have access to
that but you can but he's go see a
medical profession but there are people
there are people he is a medical
professional and so I know but he does
he doesn't work with them they go see
their local doctor you can I can but my
problem is I've been to five really good
dermatologist and with psoriasis it is a
gut issue according to a lot of people
here's what I hear they'll be on the
rope here like do that what to my doctor
they clear it up in two days so how can
take because you can like a lot of
people tell me who take biologics there
there are great drugs problem is they
come with very serious side effects so
if you take few Mara you can't get life
insurance yeah he's an idea it increases
your risk of cancer and stuff there are
ways to do it I'm a huge believer in
Western medicine Tichenor percent email
brightens dr. dan garner 88 at gmail all
you email that doc and very helpful
do that yeah is that it that's it this
weekend Austin Thursday Friday Saturday
Austin capcity I am there Austin if I
was me I could come Thursday Friday
Saturday in the next weekend I'm in
Dallas Dallas Thursday Friday Saturday
Addison improv Vancouver just got
announced that [ __ ] is halfway sold out
that things in my way chin whatever that
pop-up is or I just saw that the
Commodore Theatre in Vancouver one night
one show only September 13th Seattle
just went on sale in September and then
Philly Europe
so Austin this week Dallas next week
Vancouver coming up get them tea fat
gay.com eskimo bros shirts drop Thursday
at 5 p.m. TK comm get them that it be
that's it buddy
oh my coffee jobs this week big brown co
obvious I'll be 30th August 30 little
wears off Comedy Store Brennan you don't
know this but we're doing our best we're
doing August 30th Sunday yeah we're
doing a benefit for my buddy Dave out
what's today oh no that's all we're
always when we're getting today's July
30th comics to our August 30th me
Brennan some other special guests well I
don't know if I'm in town some don't say
I'll be there yeah I don't works on this
yeah we'll figure it out but I don't
know if I'm in town all right either way
Brian's doing a show I'll use 30 to the
Comedy Store with friends forgot right
counting friends yeah I'll use 30th yeah
tik-tok Tom all right we're out this the
final kid we're out August 30th is a
Thursday mm-hmm